[Music]
in smartphone detox news submitted by
crack in my back this young woman hasn't
touched a smartphone in eight months and
now stands to win $100,000 I couldn't go
eight minutes how is she doing this how
did she unlock this power
if this wasn't my career I'd do it yeah
I think no I can't agree with that I'm
willing to admit I'm completely weak
yeah yeah my on airplane mode right now
and I'm still topping it I know nothing
I think all of us are addicted cuz I
feel like the go-to female if they were
bored or fidgety no one goes let me
stare at some birds
you know everyone goes to the phones now
I guess dude that's a normal thing have
you ever caught yourself checking the
same website like three times within ten
minutes is my safety net too like if I'm
in public and I feel anxious yeah just
open my phone look busy pretend like a
pretend I'm getting you guys are all
slaves technology I do that when I'm
walkin addicted what are you talking
about mics in front of em like look at
this iPhone that's my big move I'm like
look at the lovin it's really pretty
nice actually
you're on eleven no I can't get into
them and that [ __ ] looks scary it's Bob
I think I'm wait-listed as [ __ ] oh he
thought we're gonna be on the same page
and it was completely opposite dude I
found twenties gonna have just 16
cameras that's [ __ ] scary that's all
I want
I want a walking DSLR I want it to be
the front-facing camera though not bad
when are they going to address the real
issues like why what good facing ones
what we need is someone to take amazing
quality photos of us but that someone
has to be ourselves
you will soon have a robot that will do
that for you oh I believe that photo
robot can you imagine to just travel
with you can get your personal
photographer like I saw this one little
drone camera huh that's what a boyfriend
is yes oh boy right now like like I
think eventually you'll have a [ __ ]
tripod that you set up and it'll take
photos for you yeah and it'll even you
can even put it in a boyfriend mode
where it takes a deep breath before it
takes over nice little drone thing that
actually follows you
like I had like the facial-recognition
thingy and then it's like did you guys
see that beta Amazon mirror test where
you just you upload all of your outfits
and you stand in front of the mirror and
you just pick different outfit without
actually having to try them on that's
smart [ __ ] cool is that see people
hate like to hate on that but I'm like
that saves so much time
yeah how cool is that people are much
more stylish yeah you know what my
friend does she says she takes pictures
of every single outfit that she buys and
then that's how she knows what she's
gonna wear that day that's the thing
that's what I want to do better and more
efficiently than mixing and matching me
too I'm like man is for shirts to pick
from gonna take forever
do you remember clueless her closet yeah
and you could see like what she would
wear she would look she's so rich I wish
I was bad rich right anyway we're
talking about Alana here so 29 year old
fiction writer from Queens and she
applied to be a participant for this
challenge and it's through vitamin water
and they have this hashtag no phone no
phone for a year contest and if this
person can actually go an entire year
without using a smartphone or a tablet
she will win $100,000 to hash tag if
she's not using her phone so this is the
initial amount how do they cap how do
they make sure she's not doing it back
in February so it says meet our official
hashtag no phone for your contestant
Alana Alana's a young adults fantasy
author who's excited to put down her
phone for a year and finish her book
series parenthesis or at least find more
creative ways to progress me give her a
follow
good luck Alana so now she's updating on
Instagram it's like how the [ __ ] are you
posting these she really is so big no
wonder easy look at what kind of phone
she has no no they took away her iPhone
gave her this vitamin water flip phone
so at least she has like all my mom
would kill education Oh
has that [ __ ] same phone she would be
like what what's the big deal yeah so
she's been using this for the past eight
month at so she does she's still allowed
geez listen to yourself somebody in Iraq
right now I was like oh I wish I had
that fall news right yeah yeah sure well
I'm sorry okay well this episode they
definitely are today grossie well yeah
so she is allowed to use her her laptop
her unlike smart things like the Amazon
echo or desktop computers she can't use
that sucker she can that's too easy then
yeah I have iMessage I can scroll
Instagram I can do everything my phone
doesn't know use it this except use it
on the toilet sure I mean you could
bring your laptop in no I use a squatty
potty so like angle of my knees I can't
put anything why do you do this why why
you don't have one no I don't want
hemorrhoids in the future but it looks
so weird hugging you know I have I have
the travel one and I keep it hidden
behind my toilet at all times and if I
go into a toilet without it I just
scooch the trashcan infront of my legs
and put my feet on that what do you do
here when there's no squatty I don't go
in public I see you hold it forever I've
held it more eleven days before dating
my fiance we shared a hotel room for 11
days well what if the kids not when
they're doing it it doesn't how because
it just comes back as attitude you baby
you sweat it off
maybe you sweat it off oh I was sweating
a lot those eleven days I was [ __ ] on
them alright okay we get it we get it
no that was she saying no I was sweating
a lot about to [ __ ] Wow I was already
sweating god never occurred
neither you did for me you can hold [ __ ]
dude even when he was at work my body
was just so scared that he would just
pop back in because he forgot I went to
the lobby of the hotel at 3:00
the morning and even then I was like
okay I have a cover story if he wakes up
and asks where I was I'm gonna say I
went to the concierge to see if they had
any advil for a headache and even then
like my body was like what if he wakes
up what if you I feel like I'd have to
[ __ ] if you don't [ __ ] I tell him what
you think about shitty no what is it ice
I have never farted in front of him and
I can't go on the same floor of the
house as him okay so he has to either be
on the first floor or on the third floor
from you guys is similar to that I am
good I was about to say that that's my
method I [ __ ] have a feeling of
[ __ ] and getting it over with is so
high for me like the reward like
sometimes I get a diary or bubble guts
on the freeway I'm like [ __ ] if I
have to pull over and just pop a squat
in the middle of the freeway I don't
give a [ __ ] is the feeling after yeah
it's like you just finished a marathon
in coop mining if we were traveling all
together and I know you didn't [ __ ] for
10 days I'd [ __ ] [ __ ] double time for
you I'll be like okay I'm just gonna
channel in that [ __ ] and then do it for
her but you're about to get married
right now and that means your
relationships going very well with this
methodology which I believe in very
strongly it's only made my relationship
better I've been with Nikki for like six
and a half years and it's I wish
shits with the door open in like the
foyer bathroom that doesn't even have a
shower so it's like this big and like I
can smell on the hallway what the [ __ ]
are you doing well he broke the biggest
rule we have to poo pourri sitting on
top of every time there's a door [ __ ]
close the door and courtesy flush oh he
doesn't know what that is he's Swedish
they're all about conserving water damn
it
so their toilets are like really slow to
go down they're so slow to go down and
the toilet seat is so [ __ ] tiny and I
don't know why they're all like 6 foot 5
how does their ass go on image they're
all their showers are tiny all their
toilets are tiny and every queen or king
sized bed is just two twins pushed
together without even a lobster clamp to
keep them together overnight so do all
of their feet just stick out of the bed
and it is hilarious to see him sleep in
his childhood bedroom when I was in
Copenhagen I had to pee in the sink
because somebody was taking forever in
the
the Batman because they know we're in
hotel and you share a toilet in the same
way did you stay
I stayed in Copenhagen what [ __ ]
hotel I have no idea I don't know
there's some plate so the whole hole I
practically lived there half of last
year so the whole floor shares like a
group bath like a glory yeah shower and
so this cat was taking so long in there
that I was like oh you in hostel yeah
okay I didn't book it this some rails
booked it but you know what you can do
instead of pissing on a sink is
subscribe to this channel because once
you hit subscribe there'll be more
toilets all over the world or more sinks
two more sinks when is a hostel when you
have your own room but then you share
the toilet and sure yeah basically even
share a room
don't say I didn't do that see someone
just [ __ ] on the floor because someone
didn't subscribe oh yeah so now you have
to subscribe again to unsubscribe and
just subscribe hi why are we talking
about this cago couldn't [ __ ] no we're
talking about a smartphone challenge of
it without yo have us I have a skinny
ass friend - we all know this special
person that shits once a week once a
week me really sure that's a week how
does this happen I don't [ __ ] know I
wish I could be better I wish I was
different I don't like being this way oh
I'm sorry I'm not judging your condition
I'm just fascinated that you can do this
and not be fat I just I feel so much
skinnier after I go what did you have
like so like so we're complement when
you [ __ ] is it like a [ __ ] no not
even it's just like really where is it
going this is it you're an absorber but
you ever just like go to a football game
nachos or something and you're like oh
god
see how I eat every day it is I
literally eat out of the garbage can
really disgusting it's all just grease
deep-fried and more grease and then put
some [ __ ] animal on top you need more
fiber does your [ __ ] know it doesn't
even like cuz I feel like your shits has
been like fermenting for a whole week
it's [ __ ] that's also been rotting no oh
thanks Bart honestly it's an unhealthy
kind because there's no smell and it
also takes forever to pass
oh you're constipated so you'll be fired
I know you need fibers cabbage are you
like Michael thank you like 5,000
calories a day basically okay that's
where this is that what it is yeah I see
I eat so much but it's either I eat
5,000 calories in a day or I don't eat
and but then you swim it off or what are
you doing you jog it off but not kind of
- no woah-oh exams how many how many
stairs could you have you live in the
Taj Mahal elevator you live at the
Philadelphia Museum some [ __ ] so you're
you're unintentionally fasting no it's
always intentional because only fast
like before a photo shoot or something
oh so like I'm a giant pile of trash
yeah well until like three days before
my shoot and then I just don't eat and
then you get all cut up for that yeah I
don't know how but like any time I've
Mackey my abs just like pop and I'm like
wait where I haven't lifted anything in
decades how old are you that's hard I
used to weigh 50 pounds more than this
so it's not genetic really yeah fifty
pounds yeah what is the secret the
secret yeah of the fifty pounds less
okay cut this out this is a joke for you
guys but cocaine and college
to be extra careful about my image cuz
I'm already like first perceived this as
a hardy girl I'll dive in the deep end
with you check this out I've smoked
crack before and I mix it with weed okay
I've never done coke girl
okay so crack isn't just smoked cocaine
no yeah I mean it's the rock form of
cocaine but you mix it with [ __ ]
baking soda and then you cook it so you
could get more out of your cane and it's
cheap it's like five bucks a hit for a
rock and [ __ ] like that to do so I never
had cocaine everyone says it's wonderful
I never did it but you know I'm not too
proud but i but i but i want to say you
have to feel so bad there's nothing else
okay oh yeah cocaine is like oops
you're a [ __ ] wine connoisseur me I'm
out here with [ __ ] malt liquor that's
cocaine I'm that's crack I did adderall
dude that [ __ ] hyper focus is the [ __ ]
out of you and you're like I could
literally do anything and then you end
up just cleaning up your house a lot
which is the but what are you gonna hit
me I don't condone the usage of drugs
[Music]
[Music]
you